although it might feel like only a short
time has passed since fans met baby luke
and leia on screen in revenge of the
sets it's been long enough for that very
same baby to grow up revenge of the
sith's film editor roger barton just
happened to have a son during filming
allowing production to ditch their plans
of using a doll for the baby shots of
luke and leia instead they filmed the
newborn aiden barton the moment when
padme gives birth isn't baby barton but
the infant came in when obi-wan hands
off luke and leia to their respective
families so what is aiden barton up to
these days in an exclusive interview
looper spoke to aiden about how he ended
up playing luke and leia and what
aspects of hollywood he's interested in
these days on whether or not martin
knows the story behind how he ended up
playing the infant skywalkers in revenge
of the sith he said
i do so i was born up in marin and
that's where my dad was working on the
movie
and george lucas he was going to use a
doll for the movie and since my dad was
up there working right as they were
filming
he's like i just had a newborn let's
just bring him in instead instead of
using a doll the scenes certainly
wouldn't look the same if the film used
cgi or adult as barton explained they
wanted to do close-ups but they really
couldn't using a doll
right so they they brought me in my mom
came in and they just put me up there
and used me for however long they chose
to we asked if barton has any interest
in pursuing acting or if he took it up
at school and he answered so my mom is
pretty big into commercial acting so she
does a lot of that but mostly behind the
camera is what i'd be interested maybe
even cinematography um i think the only
other
time i've been in front of the camera is
i was an extra in pirates of the
caribbean barjin did however put his
photography skills to use when he was in
school yeah so i started my own
photography business in
eighth grade okay cool two years and
then
kind of shut that down once high school
got pretty heavy on workload and stuff
but since then i've been doing just a
lot of personal photography stuff on my
instagram
and just stuff that i'm interested in
while barton is more interested in
photography and being behind the camera
he's not opposed to dusting off his star
wars chops to appear in a future film or
show
so i'd love to have any cameo or part in
any star wars movie just to continue
what happened when i was super young
really cool um
i think being an obi wan would be pretty
cool just because it's
kind of based on where i was as a child
and care like picking up after that i
think that'd be pretty awesome
um and of course i'd have to be a sith
barton is even willing to play a pre-new
hope luke if the opportunity presents
itself on either obi-wan kenobi or
another project
that'd be awesome i mean i think they're
pretty done with the series but
um in the future yeah totally it's
understandable why barton would
gravitate toward anything set before the
original star wars trilogy when we asked
about his status as a fan of the
universe he answered i love the movies
but i have to stick to the prequels as
my favorite okay
the new ones came out i've seen a couple
but not my favorite i'd have to say
revenge of the sith is my favorite but
that's biased
yeah
but yeah
i mean pretty pretty strong star wars
fan but based on trivia and stuff you
i'd probably get lost considering the
sheer amount of content dropped in
theaters and disney plus over the last
few years we can't see how anyone would
hold that against him the 17 year old
senior in high school is headed off to
boulder for college next year with an
undeclared major but a firm interest in
photography fans can follow barton and
his photography on his instagram at
aidenbar1
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]